[Musique]
vous connaissez miami dont vous allez
adorer
m
tandis jour il retrouve mon boulot
pépère je veux pas des problèmes
j'ose espérer que le reste de la police
française les packs en poupe
ici en mairie poursuit ce déplacement
les règlements ça va pas plaire et à
bien avec le règlement on n'est pas
forcé d'être toujours eu que deux hawk n
6 1
[Musique]
première fois à l'hôtel royal
vous pouvez choisir une chambre soit en
californie soit dans le nevada j'ai
toujours rêvé d'une suite nuptiale
même si je ne suis pas en voyage de
noces
je vais vous faire ici je vais chanter à
reno demain ça ne paie pas mais chanter
ses chantiers c'est pas un endroit pour
un traître mon père vous devriez pas
être là c'est un peu trop calme ici ça
me fout les jetons
[Musique]
ma
on a un problème comme surveiller je ne
surveille que ce qu'ils me disent de
surveiller 10h10 la direction tu crois
tu peux prendre ce qui m'appartient et
que je n'aurai pas le chercher
je m'y attendais et je me suis préparé
vous êtes perdu mon père je peux vous
faire une confession je suis pas
vraiment prêtre
[Musique]
c'est un jeu
et ça commence toujours par un simple
choix vous voulez bien ouvrir la porte
je crois pas de quel côté tu est le bien
le mal dieu pas de dieu
rouge
noir
ce serait des choses horribles comme
tout le monde c'est la vie aboud le
whisky
[Musique]
quand ma non
on peut vous parler mais dit rien il a
dérapé c'est ça toi tu me pousse encore
je te pète la nuit
bienvenue dans ce départ et mackay là
mais brasca williams lui et ses cols
pluie c'est lynch 12 mercenaires toi
pourquoi tu es là tu es tu veux pas me
croire
ali balance pec j'ai eu une prise de
tête avec un alien
au début on était tard et alors lui
c'est un peu plus rien
[Rires]
c'est quoi ça
c'est la chose qui a tué mes hommes
[Applaudissements]
la lienne
de fait
les prédateurs les exploitent les
faiblesses ratent leurs proies comme un
jeu ils ont l'air d'adorer sarthe
chasseurs sportifs puisque prédateurs on
a tous voté prédateur c'est plus cool
non ah ouais vous avez un plan
un ex nay peur traumatisée et une bande
d'allumés vous êtes dingues en fait
messieurs ils sont grands qui sont
rapides et monique sc la ridelle
tourisme
au fait je pensais je crois qu'on va
crever
juste pour dire c'est tout
notre malabar est un chasseur il a amené
ses chiens
les bars
et
[Musique]
vous ne savez rien c'est ça ou vous avez
choisi de ne rien savoir
[Musique]
votre mari m'a volé deux millions de
dollars
[Musique]
des sachets de ma fille
il s'agit de ma fille
et puisqu'il s'agit de ma vie maintenant
il s'agit de la vôtre
[Musique]
il s'est passé quelque chose cette nuit
quelque chose de terrible
monsieur vliegen votre famille faisait
partie de la vie de harry depuis très
longtemps j'ai besoin d'aidé je vois pas
ce que je peux faire
nos maris ne reviendront pas
on est tout seul
mon mari m'a laissé les plantes son
prochain casse qui besoin d'une équipe
pour aller jusqu'au bout pourquoi on
devrait te faire confiance parce que je
suis votre seul rempart contre une balle
dans la tête
ce que les hommes comme votre mari et
mon père
on appris
c'est qu'on récolte ce qu'on sème
espérons le
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour les flingues des fringues que
je trouverai où tu trouveras
si ça tourne mal je veux que mes enfants
sachent que je me suis pas laissé faire
j'ai agi
notre meilleur atout c'est d'être qui
nous sommes
pourquoi parce que personne ne s'imagine
qu'on va avoir les couilles d'aller
jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
joyeuses fêtes de noël
à
vous n'êtes plus sûr monsieur je sais ce
que je dois faire je vais leur volley
noël tout va disparaître
nous devons résister c'est la neige la
plus bruyants que j'ai entendu de toute
ma vie à aller en piste
tout ça c'est des transports première
classe
o o
non
ce matin
oui
[Musique]
aux essais alors qu'ils n'auraient
eh bien
max tu as mérité une promotion tu
tiendras montré non c'est que oui
qu'est ce que max
le grinch max tu connais le règlement
toi tu dors dans ton lit et je dors dans
mon c'est toi qui lui a appris à faire
les yeux de chatons
bon d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chico cure au sec
les gars me remplacer
[Musique]
c'est bientôt le gazon et hulot
dépêche-toi fait massacrer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bon
rue qui a fait au moins un vrai film
gamine je vais pas m'en fiche heures
bliss va permettre de perdre cette
bataille
bonjour monsieur à flers tu dis jamais
merci toi jamais ya deux erreurs qu'on
est en retard
vous allez vous reposer je me reposerai
quand je serai mort monsieur t on
monsieur chinoise elle savoir mon père a
fait un avc
écoutez c'est pas forcément d'armes ne
semble pas de la nuit vers va
pour la nuit vers de la samba quand il
dit blanc quant à tenir c'est la zone du
langage et de la mémoire qui ont été
touchés on va faire quelques tests
lio trope mardi mercantile on rassure
toi
rien n'est sorti dans la presse quand je
te laisse faut que j'aille voir la
psychopathe
quand vous tournez pas dans mon essai
par un autre moyen cheval qui courent on
dit qu'il [ __ ] presque vous sentez
comment aujourd'hui je veux martyrs
d'ici deux jours vous avez l'air en
pleine forme de revoir madame
vous faites tout pour que je vous êtes
vous et une fois vous avez ce que vous
voulez puis une nouvelle ça fait trois
ans que je me tape des études pour
quinze jours de sainté reste un tout
petit peu en moins ne sert pas des gens
comme ça ça se fait par son punch et
touffue
qui veut vendre deux mineurs c'est pas
possible amélie vous êtes sérieux là
tu cherches depuis là on sait quand tu
perds pas faire de maintenance à 7 à
mémoire là c'est la maison ça c'est toi
peut-être le plus de perdre merci
monsieur at&t a fait cas
ok ça
[Musique]